so my name is vincent and i'm going to
talk about
monads in python
so i'm a software engineer
and i have around four years of
experience in python
and it happens that i'm a big fan of
functional programming
so monads have a pretty bad
reputation in the world of programming
but have some goals for this talk
is to show that at its core monad is is
a simple
but powerful concept
and that monad can be leveraged in
python
so have some warning to give
this talk will be more practically
inclined than
theoretically illegals
so let's start with a
motivating example um
so let's say that we have we we want to
time
some functions that is to to measure the
time of execution of some functions
one way you can do it is to create a
function decorator like this
which starts the timer before the
execution of the function and ends the
timer after the execution
and then returns the results and the
time of execution
so let's have some some functions and
let's use our our new decorator
so one problem i have is how to change
this
how to change those functions and get
the total time of execution
so one of you one obvious way to do it
would be
just to to call the functions
sequentially like this and
unpack the the results the intermediary
results
and the times of execution and just some
the times
so there are some things which could be
improved
first we need to repeat the logic of
unpacking the value and time
at each step of the computation and as
programmers we don't like
repeating things
but something is which we need to repeat
we need to repeat the summation in this
case we need to sum twice
so let's introduce a function that's i
call
bind and which takes uh
which says as arguments uh a tuple
uh of of some value and the time of
execution
and a function f uh
so we you can imagine that the time
which is called in the first
which is stored in the first argument is
the time that has been
computed and accumulated so far
so the bind function is just going to
apply the function um
the value which is stored on the left at
the zero index of the tuple
and compute the the new time of
execution
and then return the results and the the
time
we had before and the new time of
execution
so with this bind function which
abstracts away
the things which were repeated before we
can
rewrite our example this way and t
contains the the total time of execution
okay um
one thing which is less nice here is
that we are nesting binds and it can be
a bit harder to
to read so
we can keep this same approach and use a
more
object-oriented approach instead so
instead of using
plain tuples let's do let's define the
class time value which
just wraps a value and the time of
execution
and let's define a bind method which
does the same thing as before
but just returns a new time value object
this way so we have to update our
our previous decorator to uh to take
this into account
to take the new class into account and
we can arrive to this results like write
this
solve the problem this way
it's the same as before but we are
chaining methods instead of nesting
functions which can arguably be
easier to read
so what did we just do we just
invented a monad the time value class
but we still don't know what is the
monad
so let's let's try to get a sense of
what it is
so monad is a general concept
with time value being one instance of it
it can be seen as a design pattern which
helps us
compose functions with effects and in
this case effects means like
measuring your time of execution
so there is there is a useful analogy
which is to say that
so you have a monad and you have monadic
values
so for instance a plane value is
is an integer and the monastic value is
a plane value plus
a time of execution so it's
it can be useful to see a monad a
monadic value as a
a a value plus a context
so what is it good for so make
composition of functions easier so as
we've seen it it made
the composition of functions with time
measurements
easier than before
it avoids repeating computational
patterns
and it but it's particularly useful when
you have a pipeline of operations like
we had before
so how to define a iman ad
okay so normally you have to define what
is called the unit function
or constructor so its role is simply to
take
a plane value and transform it into a
magnetic value
define a bind function which
encodes the logic of applying a function
to a monastic value
so i just mentioned here that
theoretically speaking you you should
make sure that unit and by
uh comply with some rules some laws
but i'm not going to cover that here and
it's pretty it's like those who are
quite intuitive
um so yeah so if we go back to our time
value example
so unit here is simply the the
constructor that we have
and bind is just yeah the binding effect
that we
that we've seen before
so let's go ahead with another example
okay so let's imagine that we have
a code like this which like
we have a sequence of computations and
at each step of the computation we can
have
known values and in this case we can
find ourselves
a checking for nuns very often
so for instance let's say we are coding
a social network and we have a user
object and we want to get
the friends of the first friend of this
user
um so in this code sample
we uh we repeat
we have to repeat uh the if else known
glass which can be a bit cumbersome
so the question is can we abstract this
away with
a monads and yes we can
we can with the so-called maybe monad so
maybe monad is one of the most simple
and common monad
that you can encounter so
what is the idea behind it so
the idea is that you can have two kind
of values
either full or empty empty corresponds
to the non value
if an mc value is encountered during a
computation pipeline
just just reforward it don't don't even
try to apply
to bind more functions and
this allows us to not to check for none
at every step
so i'm going to show you the codes and
hopefully this will be more clear
so let's try to define a maybe class
so it's simply going to be maybe simply
going to be a wrapper around
a value that we store in a in an
attribute
and unit is simply the the constructor
binds so if self the value is none
we had that means that we had at some
point encountered uh
uh some computation which returns which
returns the empty value so
we don't need to do anything more we
just we can just
return we can just return it
on the other hand if
if the the monad is if the maybe monad
is full
we can proceed with applying the f
function so we apply it to the save the
value attributes
so here there is a small distinction to
make
depending whether on that whether
f returns a maybe value or whether it
returns a plane value
uh so if if it returns a maybe value i
just returned the maybe value
if it returns a plane value i've wrapped
it
around the unit constructor so the
reason i do this is
is to be able to to ensure that we
return maybes
and that we will be able to chain more
binds in the computation
so some note for our monad experts
here i'm just completing buying the map
um and we can rewrite our previous
example
uh with the buy method this way
so we we just take the the initial value
props and
uh wrap it into the the maybe
constructor
and apply successive binds on it
uh so what's nice here is that we can
chain function without longer
non-guards because the non the non-check
is
is done once and for all in the
uh in the maybe uh monarch code in the
bind function in the bind method
is there a way that we can be more
concise and yes we can by
using the dynamics of python
so very quickly because i think i'm
lacking time
oh okay cool
so okay the idea is that
instead of doing binds of lambda object
method
what i really want to do is is maybe you
need that method
this this could be more compact
so and a natural idea that we can have
that we can have here is to use
the get that magic method
um so
okay i'm not going to get into the
details here but by defining
uh get out in some way in the maybe in
the maybe class
uh so there is some distinction to make
if uh the fields which we
are trying to access is a function or
not but the idea is the same
we can rewrite our example this way
one thing to note is that this uh get
out
thing is independent of the monad we are
considering so we could use it on
other monads of course there is the
downside
that there is some performance penalty
with by using such a thing it can be
make the code harder to reason about
um so now i'm going to talk about
the notion of monad comprehension which
is a bit experimental
so what you are going to see here is not
production ready
so uh let's let's reconsider our time
value example
uh everything went well because we had a
linear pipeline
by that i mean uh at every step of the
computation
we only needed the previous the result
of the previous step but
it's not all it's not always the case
for instance here we have a pipeline
where uh we depend the final value that
we are interested in
is the is the first value that we
computed so in the non-monastic version
of the code it would be trivial to do so
like this
but with the monadic version uh it will
be more involved
because you need to to nest binds in
order to create a closer
where you can keep x0 in the scope
so can we have something
friendlier than that
uh okay so what i really want to write
is this
so this might be night bending
but my idea is that
uh i would somehow
i would like to to modify the meaning of
the list comprehension syntax
in order to use it not only on lists but
on any kind of monads
so uh in this case the time value
uh would be a time value another list
and for x
0 in first one it would read as x 0
equal
first one dot value uh
okay so so this intuition so i'm not
going to get into the details but this
intuition
comes from the fact uh that lists are
monads
and a list comprehension can be can be
rewritten in terms of
unit and bind
so the idea is to to generalize the
syntax
of
of these comprehensions to to
comprehension
any on any monad
so if some people are used to haskell
this is very similar to the
the do notation
and but where's the catch python doesn't
doesn't allow us to
overload the meaning of comprehensions
so the solution i came up with i mean i
took his
inspiration from something so the
solution which was found
was to use asc transformations so
a small reminder when you are executing
a python program
it goes this roughly this way so you
have the python source
source code which is scanned and passed
into uh
an abstract syntax tree it's then
compiled into python
bytecode and it's then interpreted
so by asd transformation i mean doing
something like this
like taking an ast transform it
into a new ist which corresponds to new
codes
and then compile it
so with this technique you can pretty
much like make piton
python do whatever you want
so the way i did it i implemented it
is with a a function decorator
which expects as argument a class
which is expected to have
a unit and bind method
and
and given this class decorates a
function and transforms
the the semantics of the of list
comprehensions
so i haven't put the code of the
decorator here but
i can show show it to people who are
interested afterwards
and it's available on github
so it would work this way
and
the non-linear pipeline that we had
before could be written this way
so we have we have some
we need to to put the code in some
function f and decorate it with
the monad comprehension decorator with
the time value class
and this way uh what looks like a list
comprehension will
actually be a time value
uh we could so
let's see another example with the maybe
monad
so here we're just summing like
maybe five and maybe six and what we get
is
maybe eleven
so f3 terms maybe not a list and for x
in maybe if i read as x equal maybe five
dot value
um still with the maybe monad but
with with one of the value which is the
in fact the empty value we should get
gmt value in the end
and it's indeed what what we get
so now this is the solution to the
non-linear
the non-linear pipeline problem
so conclusion take away
so i hope that you are somehow convinced
that monad is not
that complicated uh
simple monads are simple to implement
and again
what i'm saying is not here is not
absolute truth you guys
many ways you could implement monads
monads are not as alien as you as one
may think
for those who know those of you who know
twisted like the deferred object is
actually a kind of monad
there are some some maybe
some maybe monad equivalents which are
found in
other mainstream languages such as rust
java promises
are kind of monad in in javascript
the link way syntax is very close to
monad comprehension in c
sharp so here are some
references from which i took heavy
inspiration
you can find the code on github and
thank you
and we have five minutes for questions
if you're leaving the if you are leaving
the room please do it quietly so people
can still listen to the questions thank
[Music]
you
[Music]
um
yeah all right
vincent